我不会去说威胁我的孩子，
如果说你不跟他分手，
我就会去破坏那个女孩子的名誉，
我就会去伤害另外一个女孩子，
因为用这种方式的话，
其实是最伤害母子情分的，
因为你是在利用孩子的善良来干成一件你想要达成的目的，
你利用孩子对别人的爱，
利用孩子的善良和责任心去破坏孩子的关系，
这个事情是万万不可取的，
这是你需要向孩子去道歉的事情。
我想问你一个关于孩子早恋的事儿，
我已经处理完了，
但是我很想让你帮我看看我处理的对不对，
或者接下来我需不需要调整。
我觉得你是个很睿智的人，
你帮我看一看，
我儿子现在是高三，
她在一个省重点中学上学，
成绩属于中等了，
她跟这个女孩子已经相识，
处朋友大概有2年了，
其实最开始到他们这个年龄我也是比较理解的，
我处理的方式也不是特别的强烈反对，
我只告诉他，
我说你不影响学习就好，
但是事情的发展好像是没有想那么简单，
后来确实是很影响学习的，
但是子的成绩一直在下滑，
在这个期间呢，
我找他都谈了好久，
也没有什么效果，
因为那个女孩子吧，
她有严重的抑郁症，
没有厌食症啊，
每个假期都要去看病，
这个就是我强烈反对的原因，
我说你们肯定没有什么将来肝。
像说其他的，
他本身就是负能量，
我感觉是负能量挺多的，
会影响到孩子都不是那么积极乐观了，
这是我认为的。
我不知道是不是一直到去年的暑假吧，
我们发生了一个争执，
在这期间我跟儿子说了好几次，
我说你就该谈的，
反正都谈了，
你软的硬的都说了，
但是还不见效，
我最后给他下最后通牒，
我说在你这儿我就该想的办法全抢了，
但是如果你还是没有状态学习的话，
我就会找这个女孩儿，
当时很生气，
我说我就要骂这个女孩儿，
我去冲她下手，
你如果要是真的你喜欢他@你不要让她受到伤害，
我也是没有办法了，
这是一种背后的威胁，
结果他真的是一点状态都没有，
把手机收走了，
他用其他的学习的那种平板跟那个女孩子联系，
有一天我看到了他还在联系，
我就很冲动，
我以为这个女孩子就骂了，
在那里面用文字骂的带了点脏字，
我就说你他妈离我儿子远一点儿，
我呀，
这样的话我知道肯定是我不对，
但是我当时很冲动，
顾不上什么颜面，
我就想给你们弄分开，
这个女孩子呢，
她知道我的手机号，
她看见我妈，
她之后呢，
给我发短信，
说的话特别脏，
就是你他妈傻，
就说了一句这样的话，
我就特别生气，
我觉得他真的是毁我三观，
我在那里也会骂他了，
不顾长辈身份或者什么不顾任何颜面的，
就跟他用短信的方式对骂了一下，
就告诉我儿子，
我说你看你就肯定要分开。
就其实我也是很想看一下大家对我这个做法的评论，
我说了我肯定是不对，
找人孩子我首先是没要管好自己家孩子的，
这个我是很知道的，
我不应该找他，
但是我确实先骂他了，
这个女孩子就是这么回复我的，
其实我就想正好闹僵了，
我想让他分开，
因为太消耗我儿子了，
无论是学习还是经历。
但是后来他们又在一起了，
我就不详细说了，
这个女孩儿呢，
可能让我儿子逼着他来道歉，
他也不太很情愿，
但是他来了之后，
我也什么都没有说他，
我认为我没有资格教育别人家的孩子，
我想既然他们高三了在一起，
不想太影响他了，
我儿子分不开就还让他相处吧，
我也向他道歉了，
我先骂人在先，
人家说我不对，
他又相处了一段时间，
但是一直到前几天发现还是不行，
首先他有严重的病，
就肯定没有后果，
他没有将来。
再有一个马上都要高考了，
我儿子还是没有什么状态，
我儿子也说在高考结束就会跟他分开的，
但现在就剩100多天了，
他没有状态，
也是发生了一些事儿，
我就告诉我儿子就早点分开吧，
确是也分开了，
想问问你怎么评论的，
接下来该怎么办？
如果要是不对的话，
把我自己带入一下你这个角色，
如果是我的孩子在高三，
她喜欢一个女孩儿，
这个女孩儿抑郁症，
有厌食症，
我想我的第一反应也会是觉得这个女孩儿的抑郁症和厌食症会不会导致我的孩子也抑郁导。
做的孩子跟他一样，
也陷入一种负面的情绪啊，
厌食啊，
对自己的人生生命不负责任，
并不是说人家抑郁和厌食，
就是说人家对自己的生命不负责任啊，
我是说会不会导致这样的一种情况，
我肯定是第一反应，
也会担心自己的孩子也第一反应是小他们分开，
想让我的孩子离这种危险吧，
离这种可能性远一点，
就是作为妈妈我觉得我最真实的第一个想法，
但至于说怎么才能让他们分开这件事情的话，
他是需要有智慧的，
需要有心理学的知识去做支撑的。
首先你需要分析的是你的孩子为什么喜欢跟这个女生在一起，
是他觉得跟这个女生在一起的时候，
他才觉得他自己有价值，
有意义，
有能够帮助别人，
影响别人的这样一种生命体验呢，
还是要扮演一个英雄，
扮演一个拯救别人，
堡护别人，
把别人从阴霾的地方带入到阳光的地方的这样一个角色呢？
如果是我的话，
我可能会从这个角度入手，
可能多咨询一些心理学的老师，
尤其是对于青少年青春期的心理学研究的比较深刻的老师，
咨询一下他们，
我的孩子为什么会喜欢这样的女孩儿，
我跟我的孩子相处的过程当中，
我是不是有点儿扮演了比较强势的，
没有让他担任一个大男孩儿，
一个小男人的这样一个角色，
没有让他满足到这一方面的心理诉求，
还是怎么样，
我可能也会反思一下自己和孩子。
相处的过程当中，
在孩子的内心，
他的渴望，
他的诉求，
我并没有真正的去了解，
从两个方面吧，
一个方面要去分析你的孩子跟这个女孩相处，
他为什么，
他的心理诉求是什么，
另一个方面要反思一下，
我跟孩子相处的时候，
是不是我太强势了，
是不是太过于让他没有一个主体性，
让他没有一个英雄情结，
男人情结，
所以才导致他会有这样的心理诉求了。
可能要调整我和孩子的相处，
但是我不会去伤害另外一个女孩子，
我不会去说威胁我的孩子，
如果说你不跟他分手，
我就会去破坏那个女孩子的名誉，
我就会去伤害另外一个女孩子，
因为用这种方式的话，
其实是最伤害母子情分的，
因为你是在利用孩子的善良来干成一件你想要达成的目的，
你利用孩子对别人的爱，
利用孩子的善良和责任心去破坏孩子的关系，
这个事情是万万不可取的，
这是你需要向孩子去道歉的事情，
如果可以的话，
今天晚上就向孩子去道歉，
妈妈做的这个事情是非常错误的，
我利用了你的责任心，
利用了你的善良，
利用了你，
你希望这个女孩儿不受到伤害的这个点，
我觉得这个是你做的最错的一个地方。
龙飞我还想问一下，
刚才我看大家屏幕，
我真的是我儿子自己，
我什么方法都试了，
我就打人也好，
骂也好，
我就谈也好，
什么方法都是最后没有办法，
这个真的不是说。
龙飞站着说话不腰。
啊，
是我真的把我自己带入你的身份，
如果我的孩子真的是我心理学的方法也用了，
诚恳的谈也用了各种方法都没有办法的话，
我也不会说去威胁她，
也不会说去伤害那个女孩子，
我可能就更多的去参与和陪伴，
如果他愿意跟这个女孩儿在一起的话，
那妈妈可以请你们看电影啊，
妈妈可以请你们一起去吃饭，
妈妈可以请你们一起去旅游啊，
我参与进来，
如果我有这个能力，
可以让这个女孩儿跟阳光，
可以让这个女孩儿不再厌食的话，
那这是我的功德，
我参与进来，
如果可以让我的孩子不至于说完全的跟这个女孩一样的话，
那也是我的功德，
请他回来吃饭呀，
有什么好吃的东西就让他带给他呀，
参与进来，
好的，
我明白了，
嗯，
飞，
我还有最后一个问题，
你能评价一下这个女孩的做法吗？
说的这个我肯定是在西安了，
但是我是这么跟我儿子分析的，
我说儿子如果他是一个别人骂他，
将来你的媳妇儿就是被人骂了，
我说的我一定会支持你无论什么样还回去骂，
回去打他就要打回去，
你们打不过我都要去帮我说，
但是这个呢，
这个女孩骂的是对象的妈妈，
他只有一种原因，
他就是要撕破脸了才是这样，
我说的他被骂了，
难道不是应该先去找你吗？
我说他就是怎么打你，
你俩是平等的，
骂你让你去帮忙出去解决，
我都能理解，
但是。
他上来就用这种方式骂我，
我说儿子，
这个女孩她是不够冷静的，
她也是没有真心，
你的感情像撕破脸了，
她才能这样的来跟我对骂。
我不知道我这样的分析的对不对，
其实你知道吗？
当我听到那个女孩儿敢于骂你的时候，
我反而心里是松了一口气的，
因为这样的女孩是有生命力的，
反而这样的女孩并不是像你所说的，
抑郁很严重啊，
或者说厌食很严重啊，
很负面啊，
她未必因为你先骂他的嘛，
他敢于骂你，
反而我心里是松了一口气的，
这个女孩并没有你说的那么的好像对生命没有力量，
并不是像你说的那样，
这个女孩儿是有生命力的，
他敢于回嘴的啊，
反而是好事儿，
那我知道了，
我怕我自己一直想这个问题想偏了，
而且你完全不用担心，
因为你大概率下95%以上的概率是以后不用跟他相处的，
你的儿子跟他之间的这种感情纠葛，
就是一种青春期的他们一个故事，
大概率下他俩是不太可能走入婚姻，
生孩子带孙子不太可能的，
所以你没必要去分析说这个女孩儿怎么样，
好的，
目光放长远一点，
你会轻松一点，
好的，
那我明白了，
谢谢大伙儿的参与，
谢谢，
好，
再见啊，
宝贝，
评价这件事情啊，
我们可以中肯的去评价，
因为客户也是带着真诚来问我的，
就是我们在评价这件事情的时候也带着真诚去回馈，
即便说你觉得这个妈妈哪里做的不对，
我们也不是去宣泄一种情绪。
而是客观的是说哪里做的不对，
为什么不对，
为什么不应该这样做，
这个单能达成共识吗？
要不然的话，
龙飞姐以后就没有客户了，
你知道吗？
就是不管是什么样的客户，
不管他干了什么，
他带着一颗真诚的心来我这儿都是好客户啊。
基本上吧，
男孩子女孩子在学生期间，
初中高中这个期间谈到恋爱，
98%以上都是成为他人生中的一个故事，
他很难成为真正的配偶，
真正的人生伴侣是很难的，
这种概率是非常小的。
记得点赞关注哦。